hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo lo
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
con el objetivo de reducir la migración
irregular y bloquear el narcotráfico
hacia su país el gobierno de república
dominica en anunció que construirá una
verja o muro en la frontera que comparte
con haití
el anuncio reabre el debate sobre si las
estructuras que separan territorios son
la solución a las crisis de movilidad
humana que son motivadas por la pobreza
la violencia y las guerras según informó
el gobierno de república dominicana la
pared se levantará a través de los casi
400 kilómetros del límite que comparten
ambos países la barrera física sería
reforzada con tecnología para un mayor
control fronterizo y los trabajos
comenzarían en el segundo semestre de
el anuncio de la construcción lo hizo el
presidente dominicano luis abinader
durante su primer discurso de rendición
de cuentas ante la asamblea nacional
según el mandatario con la medida busca
lograr la protección integral de su
frontera en la segunda mitad desde año
2021 y empezaremos a construir en la
línea divisoria entre ambos países
república dominicana y haití las nuevas
medidas de refuerzo de la seguridad que
combinarán los medios físicos y
tecnológicos e incluirá una doble verja
perimetral en los tramos más
conflictivos y una simple en la red
además
de sensores de movimiento cámaras de
reconocimiento facial radares y sistemas
de rayos infrarrojos
la propuesta del muro fronterizo llega
después de que república dominicana y
haití firmaran en enero un acuerdo de
compromiso contra el flujo migratorio
irregular en ese pacto se contemplaría
la cedulación de haitianos residentes en
república dominicana y la construcción
de hospitales de maternidad del lado
haitiano de la frontera sin embargo
dichas propuestas no resolverían el
eventual cierre con una barrera física
entre ambos países y es que la de haití
con república dominicana es una frontera
viva de continuo intercambio comercial y
tránsito e incluso sectores como la
agricultura y la construcción necesitan
mano de obra extranjera en territorio
dominicano veamos cuáles son los
diferentes puntos de vista al respecto
este es el pequeño haití un barrio en
santo domingo donde conviven haitianos y
dominicanos sus calles se han convertido
en un mercado ambulante aquí los
haitianos compran y venden cualquier
tipo de artículo residentes de ambos
países comparten esta zona desde hace
por lo menos 40 años y es referente para
los extranjeros que llegan del lado
occidental de la isla algunos en las
calles dicen que viven juntos pero no
mezclados y ahora con el anuncio de la
construcción de un muro para regular el
tránsito de haitianos los locales
reaccionan para mí ser importante porque
así se controlaría tanto la migración de
un país hacia otro no hubiera tantos
problemas como pueden existir
la república dominicana hay muchas cosas
haitiano ya que está lleno para un
médico porque está lleno de haitianos
para defensores de los migrantes el muro
es una medida que agudiza la situación
de los haitianos en la isla
es una persecución permanente entonces
la meta no es realmente un gobierno que
se dice ser de cambio y no esté
respetando mínimamente la dignidad y el
derecho de los inmigrantes incomunicada
y piden el cambio otro tipo de medidas
más humanitarias y medidas como ésta de
incrementar el control fronterizo lo
ideal es que se complementen con medidas
que promuevan la migración regular y
ordenada en república dominicana viven
10,5 millones de habitantes de ellos
500.000 son haitianos según la encuesta
nacional de inmigrantes
sobre la situación humanitaria de los
migrantes que cruzan a diario para
trabajar o realizar otro tipo de
intercambios le consultamos a pedro
manuel casal abogado especializado en
seguridad y defensa quien hizo parte del
grupo de asesores legislativos
redactores de la ley para la
construcción del muro es un tema mucha
gente habla de perfectos derechos
humanos por hay que entender de que
muros grandes es el límite es fuertes
hacen fuertes vecinos en buenas buenas
paredes son buenos vecinos entonces qué
sucede no se va como mucha gente piensa
a cerrar a separarnos de haití y no
podemos somos una isla pero si se va a
regular qué va a pasar ahora que los
contrabando de cigarrillos ilegal el
contrabando de whisky en contrabando de
alcohol de armas desde incluso de
menores que transitan por esa frontera
de un mío va a ser mayor regulado y va a
poder ser impedido aparte de eso va a
significar de que muchas de los negocios
ilegales que se daban precisamente por
esa libertad por esa facilidad que
estaba operando la frontera fiesta
totalmente ahora tendrán que tener mayor
cuidado va a elevar el costo de los
motores para quienes mantienen
intercambio
y les va a beneficiar porque porque
ahora los productos tendrán que pasar
por aduanas y podrán entonces tener el
mayor registro y pago directamente de
sus impuestos a ello le va a beneficiar
sin embargo los hechos revelan que los
muros dividen y audio en sentimientos de
xenofobia y racismo y es que el éxodo de
haitianos no solo se registra hacia
república dominicana
miles buscan emigrar hacia otros países
ante la profunda desigualdad y crisis
económica social e institucional que se
vive en su país hasta que inmigrantes de
france24 los invitamos a comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrantes f24 sigan conectados con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]